hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about learning languages in your
sleep now if you enjoy my videos please
subscribe you can click on the bell here
to get notifications
it sounds kind of silly
and honestly in my opinion it is silly
to think about learning languages in
your sleep and i'm going to explain why
but it comes up all the time
and i did some research on google and
nowhere in any of the articles written
about learning in your sleep
did it suggest that this was an
effective way of learning languages
and intrinsically to me it doesn't make
sense first of all
i can't sleep if there's noise
so
um you know if there's a tick-tock of a
bet of a clock somewhere
that'll disturb me when i'm trying to
sleep like i normally fall asleep right
away i might get up once twice at night
depending on the situation but and fall
right back to sleep again but if there's
noise i can't sleep so i cannot imagine
being able to sleep while listening to a
language that you're trying to learn the
other thing that's wrong with the idea
of learning in your sleep is that i
actually find language learning
enjoyable
i enjoy
listening to the content right now i'm
doing persian and
zachara in in iran has sent me material
on
famous poets poets old you know a
thousand years ago
20th century and i'm going through this
material and i'm enjoying it i actually
enjoy
the process of learning the language of
learning about the culture
and each of these stories i'm so
delighted when i get them and i can
import them into link and i can start
picking my way through them first i'll
go through it in in sentence mode
because it's the material is difficult
and then
as i turn the page i'll review some of
the new vocabulary this is the one time
where i find kind of going through
flashcards can be good because the
vocabulary is brand new and it's still
connected to this
context that i'm i'm reading and then i
go away and listen to it
so um
you know and and uh i mentioned the
other day i have my morning exercise
routine so
i will put the new whatever
items been sent to me
uh
i'll have that audio playing while i'm
going through my seven-minute exercise
routine where they're telling me to you
know get on the floor and do sit-ups and
push-ups and stretching or whatever it
might be
the thing is it's an active pursuit to
me language learning is an is an active
thing i find that
combining it with being physically
active also helps me learn i'm
interested in the subject there's
research to show
that we have a much better ability to
remember things
that we are emotionally connected to so
there's so much behind how we learn
languages how we we allow the brain to
to start sorting out
different patterns connected with the
language
the emotional side of the brain gets
involved
we relate what we're learning to things
we have experienced so if i'm reading
about
an iranian poet of the 20th century who
was a left-wing
politically active
and
you know this through the period of the
50s and the 60s and perhaps even earlier
then i relate this to
different
people that i have read in chinese in
french and english about different
periods of the 20th century it's all
connecting to things that i know and
this is helping me to learn it
sleep i mean i i do dream
my dreams are very
creative you know amazing how different
things unrelated things are thrown
together in
in dreams that are kind of similar it's
usually about me
arriving late at the airport or
something
with different people who are not
connected to each other and all this
kind of stuff but there's stuff
happening in your dreams so
i i have trouble imagining how even if i
could eventually fall asleep while
listening to this language
it would interfere with this other stuff
that i'm doing
and uh to me language is not something
that you pop a pill and you learn it or
you put it you know play the language
while you're sleeping
uh
it's more about actively and enjoyably
engaging with the language
so i haven't done any research
of my own
i haven't tried to do it on my own i
have googled i haven't found any
evidence that it works
and everything about
my experience with learning languages
and how i learn languages suggests that
it won't work
at least that's
my view
to me
languages are all about exploring
discovering cultures
the pleasure of of
of acquiring new words the pleasure of
allowing a new language to create some
space in your brain as you're
discovering so many
interesting things about the language
and the culture and that's creating some
emotional connections and so
so for all those reasons i i'm not
looking for any uh
sort of instant
solutions to language learning and you
might want to check out two video videos
that i did that are certainly relevant
one is about my language learning
technique and the other one is about
exploring as part of language learning
anyway there you have my take on
learning languages while you sleep
thanks for listening bye for now